et pour évoquer cette situation
économique toujours plus délicate au lit
bon sur ce plateau claude blanchemaison
bonsoir vous et soir expert en relations
internationales des déclarations du
gouverneur de la banque centrale du
liban qui interviennent alors que on l'a
vu antonio guterres s est au liban
comment est-ce qu'il faut interpréter
ces déclarations pur hasard ou un appel
du pied en quoi est ce que ça peut faire
changer les choses la réalité c'est que
ce n'est pas une crise économique c'est
un effondrement économique
puisqu'en moins deux ans le produit
national brut du liban a diminué de 40 %
donc été divisée pratiquement par deux
et que la monnaie la livre libanaise a
perdu 90% de sa valeur des produits
alimentaires à beyrouth augmenté de 2000
pour cent ce qui explique ce que vous
voulez dire dans votre sujet à savoir
que 80 pour cent de la population
parmi ceux qui n'ont pas pu s'en aller
vit en dessous du seuil de pauvreté et
effectivement c'est le moment qu'a
choisi le gouverneur de la banque
centrale du liban on n'ose plus
critiqués parce que ça fait aussi
baisser la livre libanaise mais il a
quand même une part de responsabilité
est ce qu'il dit c'est que dans le fond
le cours de la vie relève à l'aise et
probablement surévalué qui ne correspond
pas à la réalité il ajoute que cela dit
pendant 24 ans il a permis la prospérité
du libre en effet il a promis grâce à
cette politique de taux de change fixe
on pouvait avoir un dollar avec 1500
livres libanaises sauf que ça correspond
absolument plus à rien puisque
aujourd'hui si on veut un dollar eh bien
il faut sur le marché libre qu'on peut
appeler le marché noir mais c'est le
marché réel il faut plus de 20000 lire
libanaise et c'est cette politique en
effet qu'elle est une politique de
bulles financières
cultivée par le système financier
libanais sous la houlette du gouverneur
riad salamé alors le gouverneur est
intouchable parce qu'en effet il est
dans le fond la pierre angulaire de la
politique d'aidé de l'ensemble de la
classe politique
libanaise et que on voit bien quand le
fmi demande à ce qu'il y ait un audit de
cette banque centrale est bien
l'audit extérieur n'arrive pas à trouver
les bons éléments la gestion est
parfaitement opaque alors effectivement
cette situation est très délicate et il
se trouve que le secrétaire-général de
l'onu pass 3 jours au liban pendant
cette période il a rencontré tous les
responsables politiques et religieux je
ne crois pas qu'il ait rencontré le
gouverneur à la banque centrale
justement le gouverneur de la banque
centrale dont outre le fmi demande 12 à
15 milliards de dollars à d'autres pays
mais qui justement peut donner ou prêter
cet argent on pense à la france mais la
france avait demandé à ce qu'il ait des
réformes structurelles urgent du
condition sinequanone on pense aux états
unis tout le monde mais les mêmes
conditions que le fmi c'est à dire que
personne n'est prêt à donner de l'argent
à ce gouvernement argent qui disparaîtra
comme ça a été le cas pour les sommes
antérieurement emprunter alors cela des
négociations avec le fmi est en cours où
doit se poursuivre avec des conditions
très précises en matière de réforme de
réformes économiques et financières au
liban et je ne pense pas qu'un pays
européens quel qu'il soit fût-il la
france puisse se substituer à ces
négociations et à ces décisions très
très dur sans doute que devra prendre le
gouvernement libanais par contre ce qui
est possible c'est l'aide humanitaire
est en effet la france
procède à une aide humanitaire à travers
les ong présentes sur le terrain au
liban sans passer par le gouvernement
libanais
quelle marge de manoeuvre pour luan eu
tout à l'heure antonio guterres est ce à
dire que les nations unies était prête à
organiser une nouvelle conférence
internationale pour le liban mais quelle
marge de manoeuvre pour les nations
unies et pour les autres pays qui
interviennent la france les états unis
s'intéressent qu'à part un risque
d'ingérence je crois que c'est important
que monsieur gougnan sa porte un message
de confiance à la pour la population est
très important important aussi qu'il
aille voir les forces de l'onu dans le
sud du liban la finul mais je pense
aussi qu'il a cherché à coordonner
l'action de toutes les agences de l'onu
il y en a beaucoup qui agissent dans le
domaine humanitaire dans le domaine de
la santé dans le domaine de la le
soutien à l'enfance et l'éducation et
que toutes ces actions d' agences de
l'onu doivent pouvoir se poursuivre et
peut-être s'amplifier à condition qu'on
ait des garanties sur le fait que cet
argent ne passe pas par les ministères
du gouvernement libanais gouvernement
qui ne sait d'ailleurs pas réunie depuis
deux mois et s'ils ne séparait les deux
depuis deux mois c'est parce qu'il ya un
conflit politique à l'intérieur du débat
comme souvent entre nabih berri le
président du parlement et le premier
ministre est
également le président de la république
le général aoun donc dans un pays où le
gouvernement ne se réunit pas pendant
deux mois il ya évidemment une crise
politique gravissime et à l'heure
actuelle on voit bien que ce que veut
monsieur nabih berry le président du
parlement c'est dans le fond que on
retire la charge de l' enquête sur
l'explosion du port en août 2000 vain
aux juges bitar qui actuellement fait
une enquête sérieuse et apparemment a
déjà mis en examen un certain nombre de
gens proches du parti de monsieur nabih
berri il ya des pressions justement sur
sur ce juge bitar il ya des élections
qui sont prévues
élections législatives au printemps
prochain
alors qu'on parle de corruption
endémique de la classe politique
libanaise en quoi est-ce que ce scrutin
sera fiable justes
transparentes on voit bien qu'un certain
nombre de mouvements et data etc et que
les jeunes également en place beaucoup
d'espoirs dans dans sept ans ces
élections mais je crois qu'il faut être
réaliste
keira ces élections qui va se présenter
à ces élections les partis politiques
existants de nouveaux partis politiques
peuvent en effet essayé de concourir
pour ces élections mais il s'agit
d'élire 128 députés au parlement
libanais peut-être c'est ce que souhaite
en tout cas le président aoun
6 ou 7 de plus pour représenter les
libanais de l'étranger est d'ailleurs le
premier ministre a tenu des propos un
peu un plan digues eu sur ce sujet comme
si une sorte d'accord international
implicite faisait que le liban ne
pouvait pas s'effondrer alors est-ce
qu'il veut parler de la diaspora
libanaise en effet il ya probablement
deux fois plus de libanais qui vivent à
l'étranger qu'au liban et probablement
que ces libanais voudrait aussi avoir
leur mot à dire au moment de ces
élections merci colle blanche maison
pour votre analyse je rappelle que vous
êtes expert en relations internationales